des gestes bien précis présentait sobre
un protocole à respecter porter sabres
attention pour marchait en avant opa
marche
le capitaine jean-françois le bleis
entraîne pour le jour j
il sera le porte étendard de la garde
républicaine pendant le défilé du 14
juillet dans la carrière c'est lui qui
donne le pas il est en duo avec chopin
son cheval gris qu'il entraîne pour son
premier défilé
alors là on rentre dans une préparation
en vue du 14 juillet donc on habitue les
chevaux gris de l'étendard à travailler
parmi un groupe de chevaux parce que là
il ya beaucoup de chevaux dans la
carrière est en même temps je regarde un
petit peu s'ils sont en condition
physique
suffisante pour pouvoir faire le défilé
dans de bonnes conditions parce que se
défiler d'heure dur quand même
6 heures entouré de la garde à
l'étendard il donne les instructions
pour apprendre à manier le sabre
il faut dire qu'à 55 ans celui qui
dirige le centre d'instruction de saint
germain en laye depuis 2010 9 n'en est
pas à son premier défilé la gendarmerie
c'est une affaire de famille son père
l'était et lui a montré la voie en 36
ans d'ancienneté jean-françois le blake
ont le plus rapidement les fois où il
n'a pas participé au défilé du 14
juillet et pourtant chaque année c'est
la même émotion que la première fois la
première fois vous savez plus où donner
de la tête enfin c'est à dire que vous
voyez énormément de monde sur le bord de
la route qui vous acclament jusqu'au
moment où vous monter jusqu'au rond
point de l'étoile avant de descendre les
champs-elysées et c'est très intense
il ya de la couleur il ya d'écrit du
bruit c'est incroyable et vous avez vous
êtes presque spectateurs de vous même
parce que c'est quelque chose d'unique
être porte étendard c'est toujours une
fierté pour lui l'occasion de réaffirmer
chaque année son sentiment
d'appartenance à la nation et à travers
la tenue toute la symbolique de ce rôle
l'âge j'ai par exemple le fanion du son
de l'instruction donc toujours beaucoup
de symbolique les armes de la garde
républicaine
donc lorsque je serai à cheval jeux
positionnerait ceci dans la botte de
lens ça me permettra de pouvoir tenir
facilement la l'étendard la grenade de
gendarmerie qu'on retrouve à différents
endroits sur l'harnachement et
l'uniforme légale en jaune sur le tapis
pour les officiers les chaperons qui
viennent habiller la selle ou encore le
sabre modèle 1822 pour se défendre tout
un attirail que le capitaine leblay
devra mettre pour le défilé du 14
juillet